[Music]
thank you
what to make of Susan Payne's visit to
put in this week has Russia been well
and truly sucked into China's orbit
joining me to discuss is Gideon rackman
who's the chief Foreign Affairs
commentator for the financial times
Gideon rackman thank you so much for
joining us on spectator TV now this
week's sitting ping visited Putin in
Russia and it was full of pomp as
expected what was your takeaway from
that three-day meeting well I mean I
think that
more or less as expected it was kind of
big reassertion of Russian Chinese
uh friendship and
um based around I think a mutual
antipathy towards the United States and
if you read the closing document it kind
of reiterates the idea that
this is all America's fault that America
is out to cement its Global hegemony
that and that both Russia and China are
kind of have been targeted by America
and that that their joint interest is in
is in pushing back against that
um I think
there was actually rather Less on the
peace Initiative for Ukraine I thought I
never took that that seriously but I
thought they would make more of it
um but there's you know if you look at
the nine point statement it's not really
very much emphasized so I don't think
even for public relations purposes
they're making much uh of the idea that
China is going to bring peace to Ukraine
I think the big issue though that that
you wouldn't really expect them to
address publicly but that the Americans
and everybody will be watching very
closely is is China prepared to give
Russia weapons and in particular
artillery shells because the Russians
seem to be running out of those
um their bombardments of Ukrainian
infrastructure are fairly sporadic now
and that's probably because they don't
have enough missiles but China has a lot
they they use uh the same kinds of
missiles that the Russians use so if
they were to ship them over to Ukraine
that would be a big game changer in the
war
um so far uh you know there was
certainly no public statement to that
but everybody watching quite closely I
mean not just in the next weeks but in
the coming months as to whether China's
prepared to
back up its rhetoric with explicit
military support for Russia and I want
to get onto that Military Support point
in just a little bit Gideon but first of
all you know your point about it not
actually being as much about mediation
as it might have seemed uh before the
visit I mean seemed like he had a wish
list of things that he went to get for
China itself including for example this
power of Siberia 2 pipeline which now
channels Russian gas to China instead of
to Europe is that what he's there for
mainly to get Chinese national interests
satisfied
well I mean I think actually you know
talking to the experts it looks like
Russia is Keener on the power of Siberia
II pipeline than the Chinese because
um there's already power of Siberia one
uh you know it's a bit like Nordstrom
one and Nordstrom two and that that's
the one that takes gas to to China from
nearby Fields Russia has a dilemma now
because all the gas that was selling to
Europe it can't sell to Europe now the
that has been doing so over the last
year but Europeans have basically been
devoting themselves to the last year to
finding other sources LNG or you know
Renewables whatever and now Russia's got
this this gas that they may not be able
to sell so they need a second pipeline
to get it to China but even on the
Russian timetable that won't be until
2030.
um and then I think that clearly you
know a lot of Russians
um are concerned maybe not willing to
express it publicly unless they're in
the opposition uh about Russia's growing
economic dependence on China you know
that if you read the statement it's all
about this is a relationship of equals
but it looks increasingly unequal
because essentially the rut the Russian
economy is was already much smaller than
that of China if and the massive
sanctions in the west so
you know from anything from
semiconductors 5G consumer goods they
can't get from the West
they've all got to get it all from China
and that puts she in in an immensely
powerful position
um and even if he didn't exploit it that
much now I think it must make the
Russians a little bit nervous about
how that relationship is going to unfold
because I mean if you're looking really
kind of back into history that as you
know Cindy you know a lot of what is
Russia now was China in the 19th century
uh and now that of course the Russians
and Chinese say and it's technically
true they don't have a border dispute
it's all settled but um I think some
Russians do I'm worried about that in
the background absolutely and when it
comes to this dialogue between China and
Russia then Gideon I mean some on the
Chinese side might say that that's what
makes China the perfect mediator if it
ever came to that that's why its peace
plan is relatively sincere and uh
substantiated because you need a
mediator that can talk to both sides in
order to do that and China might point
to the iran-sa Arabia deal that it
recently brokered where those two
countries hadn't been speaking since
2016 and now ah thanks to China's
negotiations what do you say to those
people well I think it's not obviously
unreasonable point I mean I think that
if you wanted a mediator you need
somebody you can and talk to Russia and
you know people have floated India maybe
or turkey I think the difficulty is that
although China presents itself as
neutral in this
um conflict it's not really perceived
that way in the west because they have
had this uh or possibly more importantly
in Ukraine they have had these
protestations of unlimited friendship
which actually are interestingly a
phrase that did not occur in this latest
statement which suggested me the Chinese
might slightly regret that because it's
been thrown at them so much but you know
the spirit of Limitless friendship is
still there in the statement and I think
that the ukrainians said well fine you
know we don't mind if China comediate we
accept that you know as we were saying
China's got a lot of Leverage over to
Russia if it wants to use it but that
the Chinese uh have at no point
condemned the Russian invasion and they
have at no point said well Russia's got
to give back the occupied Ukrainian land
I think even if they were to be neutral
on Crimea if they they were to just say
look well Russia's got to withdraw to
the lines it was before The Invasion a
year ago that might be seen as a kind of
earnest of good faith in enough in Kiev
to make them feel well okay they could
they could talk but I think if they're
not prepared to do that and if they
endorse the kind of Russian World View
which is this is a proxy war fought by
the United States this has really got
nothing to do with uh Ukraine's own
volition then I think they they kind of
lack credibility in this and I think
that as you say the Saudi Iran thing was
really interesting and I think a big
breakthrough for the Chinese and one
there can be you know maybe justifiably
proud of but it was a very different
situation that Saudis and the Iranians
were wanted to come to a deal they had
been talking behind the scenes for about
18 months and the Chinese were able to
step in at the last moment and you know
provide literally the good officers you
know they can meet in bed in England
provide a hall and do that but I don't
think that um
that you know this conflict is similar
because the two sides are not looking to
settle and of course this is absolutely
right to say China is not completely
neutral on this I mean it is talking to
Russia but presidency hasn't spoken to
president zielinski at all since the
invasion started but we're hearing that
a phone call might happen at some point
this week do you think Ukraine has
slightly more complicated uh
relationship to handle here with China
because when and if the war ends
presumably Ukraine wants Chinese
investment to resume in the way that it
had they had before the war
yeah I I think so
um the ukrainians obviously
even in the midst of a war have to be
reasonably pragmatic and try to think
about what the world might look like
afterwards and you know there is a
a lot of Chinese investment through the
Belton Road going across the Eurasian
land mass Chinese construction firms
could potentially you know if they're
big U.N contracts play a role um in
Ukraine and why make an enemy
um prematurely if you don't need to but
that said I think it was extremely
interesting that in the very days in
which she was in Moscow kishida the
Prime Minister of Japan was in is in
gear and so you almost feel like the two
great rivals in East Asia are picking
different sides of this war
um and and sort of you know for all the
talk of proxy war maybe it's now also
becoming a proxy rivalry between China
and Japan goody
um and Gideon finally you know you
mentioned military aid at the beginning
um on the latest Chinese whisp was my
podcast I spoke to senior Colonel jobor
who used to be in the people's
Liberation Army so pretty much as
establishment as you can get and I know
that he's written for the financial
times previously as well and he was
pretty clear that the Chinese would not
be giving Military Arms not because he
was trying to spin me necessarily but
because he was saying wouldn't be in
China's interest to get involved in that
way because then China then becomes even
more of a baddie but you don't seem to
think that that completely rules out
this idea of military involvement no I
mean I don't I mean I I hope he's right
um because obviously it would be a
really dangerous escalation if they did
it and very bad news for Ukraine
incidentally
um but I suspect that you know Beijing
is a bit like Washington or Moscow there
are debates
um you know they may be a bit more
hidden in a in a society like China as
well where they don't obviously
encourage people to descend from
whatever the line is
um but there will be discussions going
on I would imagine uh that there's a
counter school that will say look
um what Putin and she said is correct uh
America's targeting both of us and uh we
cannot afford to let Russia lose so they
may not do it now but if they actually
saw a real danger of uh Russian
capitulation there might be a temptation
to do it just as you know if Kiev was
suddenly under threat again a lot of
people in the west would say you know
get as much Aid as you can to Ukraine
fast I think that you know stalemate
they can live with a Russian defeat
might or the prospect of a Russian
defeat might open up the question of of
direct military aid or you know it may
even be under discussion now the
Americans say that actually they think
the Chinese are sending stuff to uh to
uh to Russia not yet the very visible
artillery shells that would be crucial
but drone technology there's some you
know a large uh Consignment of what
we're called hunting rifles went uh from
China to Russia uh semiconductors would
do all use that kind of thing and they
can always root stuff
um you know through third parties so I
think the US is pretty concerned about
this and presumably uh they they are
listening to and watching what's going
on in Beijing quite closely great to
have you on the show thank you so much
[Music]
foreign